welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by Sam Holloway who is the
director of that recruitment company who
are a specialist tech recruitment
business that focus on building teams
and helping scale ups in the Netherlands
and Germany markets Sam thank you for
joining me yeah good to have you on here
so for those that may or may not know I
I did do an interview with Sam's boss
and a little while back Chris stringer
so obviously Sam would you dive into it
but you've obviously been on the ride
with Chris I'm excited to get your
journey your perspective your story as
you is the first hire for Chris mmm it's
gonna be I mean I'm excited to get into
it from your point of view it should be
cool um first question mate where I
always always like to start on this
podcast is how did Sam enter the weather
equipment let's start there Oh difficult
question I'll be honest for complete
accident I never drove to be no Dakota
I'll be completely honest but I you know
as a boy I wanted to be a police officer
an armed response officer and as most
people do feelings in the world of
recruitment you know and it's been good
I've actually wrote a short blog on it
as well if people do want to have a look
at but this manager car salesman and I
always say this to Chris I decided that
you know one day that recruitment for me
I asked you first heard the word the
crewman I didn't have a clue why he
really entailed for a friend and couple
of conversations later me and a basic of
21,000 him on a basic of a little bit
more than that a smashing sales and
earning 40k applause when he was the
same age kind of you know showed you the
dream yeah he told me the dream and he
really did and teach
I'll get you never come through so ended
up going with a wreck to wreck you
actually got me a couple of in you so I
think for use the same day couple of
companies in Chris was actually my last
one to tell you the truth right the end
of the day and here we are enjoying the
Chris stringer so yeah I guess just a
friend mark then for people listening in
the contest so join Chris joined that
recruitment company and obviously been
there now for six years which is a
really I'm sure you sort of gathered
this now looking at other people and you
interviewing people for the businesses
stuff is a real long time to be at one
recruitment firm right and just just
just to sort of frame up in that the
concepts as well so when you join Chris
is as you and Chris which it would dive
into but and then now you're at your
where are you as a business there's like
what six or eight of you is there no
these we're looking at 10 actually I
recently which is quite cool we hired
during co-lead really we good God and
we're still growing still looking to
inhibitor obviously comes through these
difficulties and we okay cool so why did
you join Chris so obviously out of those
four businesses Chris obviously it was a
business of just him right at that point
was that
it was to be honest with you I have no
idea jokey Chris his dog and an office
that wasn't even I mean he hadn't even
renovated the office at this point so it
was a big big big gamble for me but I'm
all about I've always been one for I
like a little gamble and this one it's
just a pale to me a lot more I need for
a high Jharkhand recruiting company and
I and this just just just just had
something about it and actually when you
really meet Greece and you you have he's
a good guy I actually don't know but
then the gamble would pay off natl but
I'm glad I took the job and actually
it's put me in good stead for the future
and actually I've really enjoyed the
ride so far it's had its troubles maybe
ask you know we've experienced growing
pains experienced hearts of pains but so
I guess for people also no you haven't
experienced anything else but I guess
like as we're talking about cuz I think
a lot of people that are in recruitment
now or considering it obviously there is
that sort of should I join a bigger big
firm or should I join a small grown
business but for me I'm we sort of
spoken about this quite a bit but I
think for me I I joined a smaller ground
business and one of the sort of big draw
points for me was the the person I
joined the owner of the business I get I
got Sam set next to that person super
experienced and I really felt that I
could learn really easily and from the
best people around me and I had direct
access to these people there's a smaller
business so I guess like I'm sure you've
had these conversations now but what
what's your sort of key positives that
come up for you when you were talking to
people about considering a recruitment
job in a smaller ground business would
you say what been the key posters view
in the six year period well yeah I mean
it was though I mean Chris Boucher's got
HP is right he spent he spent ten years
on the market before I even entered the
world of recruitment and I thought okay
this is my opportunity to sit next to
the man himself see next to the man
that's already built engineering
division and actually no actually you
know always accountable
responsible for a lot I mean back then
the only responsibility I had was kind
of you know we've had a clean pair of
boxes in the drawer I was scary but it
was empowering and I learned a lot from
Chris because I was next to Chris here
how did this I'm actually watching and
listening that's where a big deal up and
he just kind of went from there and I
found that I had a naturally and
actually till this day I still enjoy the
full process are still enjoying the 360
process and it was the the idea that I
could join somebody in a smaller company
where I would get the training and you
know management it was just I knew that
I would get the support needed yeah I
think Chris tries to install we have
we're not a big company so we don't have
the VA and the DB part but he's a big
believer that he will you know we have
external training as you know we try and
leave everybody crystal says I will give
every person that joins his business
form the tools to to make money and yes
actually do we do that and awesome
okay so always interested to hear about
people's first year more equipment
because it's normally really difficult
do you increase the dog in a renovated
office obviously have Weitzman Creamery
before don't care car sales which
services is a real different type of
cell right I mean I came I came from a
insurance sales background which was
super transactional if I didn't close
that person on the phone I went here and
on him again so for me the sort of draw
going into recruitment was the sort
consultive side and along the sales
process learning how to do that and more
consultative and obviously making more
money more a bigger deal values or those
types of things so I guess but my first
year was really difficult it mostly all
I heard about was the good things in
recruitment right before I got into it
so I guess what did that first year look
like for you Sam what went on in that
first year it was it was difficult but
it was it was entirely rewarding I I
said
to myself before I was going to take me
some petunia it was gonna put everything
into this opportunity yeah don't get me
wrong time to change their week now I
used although it was just me increased I
used to walk into the office what I'd
like say sube damn boo me but it was
more like jeans in a blazer I'm sure
every single day Turner and I'd be ready
to work
it was difficult the first six months I
say to everybody the first six months
should be the most difficult should be
the most difficult job you've ever had
but once you've rode that six months it
then becomes the best job it's all about
what you put in like way me and money
Chris's focus was to grow the team to
two to three
and actually just to get as much money
on the board - Taylor - but then you
know an eight thousand or of deal was a
big thing pretty sturdy one I used to do
one and then basically a first Dale I'll
never forget in 29 days 29 days what did
you what did you bill in your first year
my so I started in June so I always look
at it kind of what better starting the
June yes
so in that months I did 47 thousand
euros and I blanked in a market and for
the child's experience
Oh obviously Chris would they help you a
lot right but I guess people may be now
thinking about opening up new markets or
doing it like like I guess what did you
focus on Sam was it the candidates saw
that you really focused on or was you
straight
bringing in jobs like what was the focus
in those first six months that helped
you achieve that do you think well we it
has to be be definite and Christian to
me actually I think back then it was you
can't we don't I don't mean to a good
candidate to you got you first five jobs
are really um yeah I don't you know I
don't smoke and ER and I quickly got
that and I quickly start working
processes but I did something that Crete
still
it was quite clever for me until these
days with Christian me and market and
PHP and actually I thought it was tough
and I couldn't I just couldn't I
couldn't grasp it
so what Addie was a kind of switched to
front-end development and I was doing a
few thinking front-end development
keeping PHP running and then that's it's
a quick look I'm gonna go and put their
friend in development because I had a
load of candidates busy pipeline and a
lot of jobs coming through and since
then I mean good switch and I haven't
looked back I work in the JavaScript
ecosystem now but still do a bit of PHP
books JavaScript twister that's my bit
in black really yeah so you ended up I
ended up pivoting slightly and yeah I've
seen a gap in the market and I took both
hands so how did you start bringing them
jobs minute I know it sounds simple and
basic right but I think one of the most
common topics questions that people ask
me to speak to people like you about is
is business development let you you now
have people around you in the office and
have done and that typically can be this
all part of the 360 role that people
find most difficult you know I
definitely found that quite difficult
early on and I mean as you as you said
like was in car sales five months hours
experience and then you're you're
calling tech firms in that saddam and
netherlands or even the germany at that
point like what yeah how did you how did
you bring these people on what was the
approach would was there any sort of
plan there was a plan
well I had my own plan but to be
honestly it was about picking up the
phone and I never I never dealt a bad
call because I always thought that too
you know tomorrow the new day and
actually that bad call he just had
they're not gonna remember you tomorrow
so for me by tomorrow I just went in
with a structured plan and I for and
having the leads on it and I had that to
go and I just relentlessly just going
through it and kept going through it and
and and and with that I mean it's very
difficult to build at market knowledge
straightaway but I started connecting
the dots and started really learning a
market and still today
I really do am I an engineer yeah when
you say that would you mean that you
like your sin I know the firm's that are
growing the fastest I know where where
the good opportunities are for front-end
developers a lot when you say you know
your market inside that what do you mean
by that
I am quite a spreadsheet or a teacher I
have my top I have top 50 can that's a
track where they move where they're
going
sometimes what post of interactively I'm
always looking at companies and their
growth and what they're doing in and
actually talking to people a lot of
people don't give some people the time
of day I do and actually trying
information like try and get as much out
he's cool whatever I can and it build
big build my market knowledge to go to
the next candidate to to hit the next
client you know these guys and I've done
a good job in almost build you taste and
kind of share that with them and that's
how I learn the market inside that we
sponsor a lot of events as well so I
tried to get involved that way by
sponsoring friend meetups and stuff like
that so people knew that I could given
it will be back but also relevant and I
wasn't you know I know the difference
between your in JavaScript which was
done just know just knowing okay it's
not an easy thing to do but I would I
would say to anybody you've got to do
that if you're gonna do rock what went
on in the next six months and sounds I
had a pretty good start considered never
done that market before you increase
what went on in the next six months did
you did you get the third person and
then or was it still you and Chris well
yes we did so 2015 i believe we made our
next higher and maybe journeys every
time and you know we just we just kept
building and building week as well and
that's part even problems that you have
for me i had one job and that was the
point as much on the board as possible
and chris dealt with you know the
internal indonesian stuff like that and
growing team so he was more
obviously guy that I'm going to give you
as much money on 2015 was a good year I
think I've finished on think Chris just
baked me that year I'm a seven and I
think he got one for my man that's on
top of the box on top of this or fifty
granny did in the six months that's that
yeah yeah so that genu genu so yeah
pretty much so yeah and your first year
pretty much all - yeah Illinois yeah I
run the gram right brand-new market a
lot was I mean you please strike me as
someone that's resilient or got the
mindset of line I'm gonna make this
happen I'm gonna belong get up and go
attitude right we're weird where did
that come from I have no idea my parents
really wasn't going to I do the same
with everything going going
this is where I want to doing this you
all want to achieve and actually great
opportunity and I wanted to impress as
well and Chris really said look he's
right you could be a cornerstone and
that's me I have become a cornerstone
and I just wanted to I wanted to I could
say that I could do it know what to
constantly improve every doing something
different try different things I was
never I was one of the worst painful
Christians ever took on on the phone
he's sure I was on an awful I've got a
very very strong accent I couldn't
believe sentences together and I just
tapped it to pick it up and continually
just develop myself and actually you
know he's a different place and I had to
learn it's okay so I guess just to sort
of wrap up this first year in May I
guess you've now seen people in the
business go through their first year and
maybe help them through that being
involved that see things I guess so
looking back now you're 6 years into
your recruitment career right like look
at looking back now hindsight what for
those people that maybe in that first
year found a difficult war I find the
challenging right now
what should go to advice for people in
that fair share resiliency is one thing
but I have this thing I could bat
already I say that you've gotta be
you've got to go eat you've gotta go in
fighting all times you know you're gonna
have bad call you can out-cook course
celebrate you small wins as well I don't
do that enough now you know because I
think okay you know I can do when you're
ready whatwhat's a small win for you
like what do you make sure that the guys
celebrate when that early on
what's the small it's not even you know
what information did you get interviews
a small room from the you know talk
you're talking to the right person you
know I'm a big believer just just the
small little things that people forget
to celebrate it's not all about doing a
deal or you know getting city news that
week
I mean to example last week I had some
conversations with companies and never
thought I've got to get in San Francisco
based companies huge enterprises and I'm
there talking to the director of Google
and that for me that's a bloody big win
yeah I think really important yeah
definitely celebrating just celebrating
good conversations or people getting
back to you or getting fruits people is
it's definitely a great small winter
celebrate some resilience but so when
you say battle-ready you see are you
talking about making sure that yourself
that they know what your intentions are
know your goals are for the week or I
don't know what what I mean you've got
to be really coming with the right
mindset coming with you go plan come
meet you I'm a big believer I don't
often finish work and go I've had a bad
day I always think you know what I've
achieved what I want I'm you know with
objects you go out to achieve something
you guys get a change there are many
variables but go out there and achieve
what you want to do and as old-school as
it is I still write the same on the same
way for piece back of every single day
what about doom I think is a good day
what my what my business needs but what
my desk needs and what I need to do to
make sure yeah I love that so I may or
may not evolved as you just said but one
of the most common subjects or topics
that people want to know is and how do
people structure their days so I guess
just for context we'll go into it but
over the six years I know it's not all
about this but I think because the
reason why when I saw about this is
because a lot of people so a typical two
things first thing a lot of people know
about the structure of people's days
right but secondly people know people
stretch a day who are billing over 200k
friends okay wherever the number is that
ultimately a real big topic that people
ask is Hisham I've build a hundred
eighty a hundred fifty a hundred sixty K
for the last two years three years and
I'm just really finding hard to get to
push through that glass ceiling and a
lot of the time people want to know how
does Sam the 250 K below or whatever
maybe structure his day is does he do
anything differently what's his process
what's the structure right so I guess
one water structure and I guess just
emphasis that what what what's been your
best performing the MA over the last six
years and we'll break it down but it
would just have the contact one year was
2000 on T last year 67 and it was a
fantastic year really good year for
everybody in the business and wasn't
just million people but that was my best
year and he pulls down to don't get
complacent yeah there was a time where I
had to reflect a lot on 2018 I thought I
did I did some good figures I think I've
got about 270 I could have done more
so I stripped it back and how could I've
done what I had was a call of good
client that I undertand I had good
relationship I stopped doing
he's the business development as much so
I'll do the business but it wasn't it
wasn't to the intensity that I would
before so what I did was I when I was in
nineteen I got the clients I know I can
build X Y Z how can i how can I
stretched how can you okay fifty K where
can I get
from write to increase it yeah yes yeah
and that was it an ee ball dancer
relationships you've got a says for you
it came from new business rather than my
maximizing the relations that I have was
it more than do you put that extra
hundred K on top down to the new
business rather than yesterday like
really
newbies nice but also quite royally
maximizing the maximizing the
opportunity for the business and what I
wanted to do was maximize it for
everybody and I brought all stuff bill
probably 367 something like that I
probably brought in 200 for everybody
else and that's what I really kind of
focused myself I'd targets from Chris as
well in order to get to direct and
that's what I really wanted to kind of
do and yeah relationships will
continually spinning these plates
continually making all that taken 20
people through you know a that's that's
awesome and a lot of people were a lot
of people will be listening to that and
go how the [ __ ] is done that like how
has he got to that because a lot of
people may not think that's possible
right and I think because I've had this
conversation a lot of people where it's
like a bill 280k it's you and whatever
the number is but it's very easy to go
that's as much as I can do have the
relations I have but it's been Oh having
the humanity to reflect look well where
are the opportunities what what have I
become complacent with so I'm keen to
really dig more into that but I guess
you can talk about 2018-2019 maybe or
whatever but what would the typical
sounds they look like that let's break
it now deep just before going to dig
into that a little bit more so what
really helped me and I'll be completely
honest we took on a guy that's kind of
exclusively focused on candidate
delivery so what I was able to do was
focused on the Big D whether he lapsed
or whether it be new and actually I knew
that this guy was feeding me these
candidates and it just made my job
easier okay
I love candidate work but what he
enabled me to do is have I went to
market my products okay I've got I've
got these guys do you want to see them
kind of thing and that that's what
really we have to tell
did you not have that in 2018 no and
you've been both see no I think it just
starts I think you started yeah that
last of that okay it will s def it
against that because I think that's
obviously an important factor right but
just quickly structure what order the
typical Sam they look like easy like
took I know I know you may think people
do people actually care about this but
they do so like what so what you get in
the office what's the first thing you do
and how did you break up your day yeah
so I always have a day plan so going
with a structure don't know but this is
this is what I need to do and for me the
Netherlands I mean they're in our head
so you have to proactively plan out your
day right so you need to be eating in
job or whatever you've got respond to
anything that's coming over the night
applications whatever soon as soon as
you connect I have o'clock comes which
she's nine o'clock there's on you need
to be in 2d and I like to I'm a big fan
of going to go to my and I don't stop
until I've got that candidate three four
I'm a big always a so how many do you
want
how many five are getting five they want
three will get them free and they don't
stop till till have done that but the
structure is simple busy get on use your
phone we're too you've got your video
technology and stuff now there was a
time and a place and worked really well
but fundamentally the bare basics will
always work and you see so you getting
in looking at the job boards looking
like stuff that's come in and then what
you're doing what BD from one eight and
eight nine to twelve what we're done
yeah we're talking from from from Eric
lots and about eleven o'clock who's
eleven o'clock up there is end those and
then that's where I'll do my admin
schedule my interviews I put some put
jobs on put there
III
so I'm pretty poor hit but that's where
I'll try and get my admin on and yeah
you know anything that's and then water
them off and then off the admin lunch
what we're doing can be leading really
yeah baby it's slightly different now
but I'm talking okay hours we'll just
quickly what what does a sound
preparation that like cuz like for me
what when I was think back even even now
my own business right when I have when I
block out a time to do a BD session and
that's all I'm doing
mmm-hmm like when I've always maximize
that time when I've like prepared like
who I'm gonna call
I wanna do blah blah blah so I guess be
interested to talk about that for a sec
what is this sound prepara because like
you're doing that for a long period so
you must it's you can't just sort of be
willy-nilly just like alright I'm gonna
call this person and I'm gonna call that
so I guess what when you're going into
that time what have you prepared have
you got a list of people that you want
to speak to have you got I don't know a
search when they go in LinkedIn and the
horrid man is originality like what what
did you make sure you've got prepared
for that BD session and that time yes so
no - I'm really religious with my
calendar so I always plan callbacks if
I'd had a positive call just a good
conversation what star would battle then
actually sometimes a case er you know
what I'll give me a call back tomorrow
look those in because that's come up a
few times so like if some if you call me
and I go that Sam's not busy time blah
blah blah I mean it's not good time
coming back tomorrow
are you saying okay Sam what time
occasion what happen yeah yeah I'd be
like yeah okay what time works you
towards the end of the day and I've made
sure one theater called everything time
because actually punctuality is one
thing and and actually do you know what
you know okay he was busy yesterday
probably isn't you remember you I'm the
god called yesterday and just just keep
keep keep feeding you know you've got to
do it has to be such points because you
know you don't know what people do
people are amazed people are busy paper
on lunch and you know you've got a deal
I'm RELIGIOUS everything in my calendar
Paula we shall talk about this just
pointless for me to go up really and
then and then yeah and then and then do
you go to the that time with like target
lists and all that then do you plan all
that out
yeah planning everything now I always
used to plan myself a certain we used to
be made out to clients now it's a little
bit more there's a lot more you don't
really work as they used to use account
now it's fairly kind of targeted
approach we do a lot of marketing
campaigns and really for me it's going
the relevant knowledge and the video
have at the minute because I work with a
lot of people I have the content so
we'll be good like it'd be great if you
could just share and talk about your
sort of expect I know he's mentioned
earlier loosely but so people might be
listening here in the process of booth
Annelle and their desk or building out a
new market might be new UK might not be
but I think I mean we had loads of
conversation in this podcast or I spent
a lot of people who were really keen on
opening up in America market or just
international markets right so I guess
what what's been your learning through
that I think you said early obviously
the Amsterdam Netherlands culture and
markets were slightly different but what
what's been your learnings for that mate
for people that might be early on that
how like how was that how was their real
push back on salmon recruiter from the
UK help me and Evelyn scale up or they
know what there wasn't I mean English
cruise down after besties and actually
going to a foreign market where you know
the best the the best thing I like about
the Dutch is they are strikes to the
point and almost a [ __ ] and you know
you're gonna get not back not back a lot
but from
you know keep going and actually I
learned quite quickly
you guys are direct and actually do you
know what I need to be a little bit of
direct but I need to have fun with it I
would joke on the phone leaving
something little something to to
remember you by
and make sure you never the two percent
of jobs are all on the first call to two
percent I think is and actually touch
points I think if you're touching base
five six times that's where you increase
your chance to call in a job so I think
I know we said that we'd um sort of
segue into this later on but I think
it's been one of the most again just
common topics that people want to know
about right now in terms of light and I
know this is something that obviously
clear you're passionate about and is one
of your strongest skill sets in terms of
new business when new clients business
development people like I've had so many
questions on how people are approaching
that now
so let's definitely talk about it maker
you're talking about different
touchpoints you're talking about two
percent of jobs get pulled on the first
call like what what does what does
business development like for you now
and sort of how have you had to maybe
adjust or like how are you approaching
it that maybe people could sort of
benefit from because I think that's
definitely a challenge right now for a
lot of people even more so I stayed busy
I've not let this define my day on the
week and actually I've seen there's a
lot of positives need something not just
at home my son but actually everybody's
in the same situation
so everybody's mindful everybody going
through the room going through this in
their own way so I used it as a time to
kind of rebuild a solid foundation at
times it might try different things and
most of all really what people want is
they want support I don't want a hard
sell they want support and they want you
to share a relevant market knowledge you
know you know your competitor they're on
board in this way or they've just lost
this and that people get you recruiters
are a founder knowledge like it or not
we're talking to people all day every
day and if you take that information
you can go to market and really open
people and to be honest I'm busier now
than I've ever been
I'm on the phone although my phone time
lots of you family people more people
are more accessible 100% anybody tells
you different he's 100% everybody sat at
home in there in this work in this wet
pants and you phone them and you know
conversations you talking to these
people about Sam because like like if if
you call me and I'm going that Sam we're
not hiring like we can't even think
about that right now
what what would like because I think a
lot of challenges right the sort of
common challenge that I'm hearing from
recruiters right now is that like again
back to sort of celebrating wins or
whatever the sort of wins might change
slightly because Sam maybe three six
months ago might have made twenty had
those cool times and pulled X amount of
jobs but now you're putting in the same
output but not book might not be getting
the same wins as you're used to do not I
mean so I guess what what you make it
what are you doing and what what are
your intentions knees cause to make sure
that you're maximizing that core time
and those opportunities well I'm being a
consultant rather than you know being a
consultant I it's a soft sell for me
wise in fact what I've stopped doing is
going for the jobs don't speak don't
speak it's not you know your company
today read a bit about you actually I'm
working with these guys she has since it
shares some relevant stuff you know
however things you know the team
adjusted to the new I love support and
what we've been doing is sharing with a
few white papers that we've created a
bit of marketing stuff how we're
combating Co V how we're still helping
people on board we also what I did which
is quite not we have that health and
mindfulness coach somebody said I have
an hour and I took that content it
really helped me and what I've done is
sherry to be kind but it sounds a bit
what I went to might and I've got this
if you want to share me team I think
reset you because it wasn't this these
guys called me for some jobs it's
actually these guys in unique airs you
sharing sharing best practices and wants
to know a little bit about us and all
these calls I've got backing my diary
actually it's really worked it beeped
really worked with people and I've got
some fantastic jobs for me to really
have yeah so you haven't been leading
with jobs you yeah it's been how we
doing what's going on you're being a
human you're sharing sort of what you
guys are doing how you're adapting and
hopefully that gives value and helps
other people and helping that lead the
conversation and yeah as you said
naturally that can lead to oh by the way
some what you guys do and can you help
me with this or yeah we want you to want
you to times one thing what they want me
to everybody's tricky situation which we
haven't mastered it by far we've had our
own problems during this but you know if
we can share content and you know you
have to let a few team members go I'll
happily help them for free just showing
that you're there to support and
masterstroke it's not but that's what's
work for me and staying busy
it's too busy I think yeah I think
whoever listens listening that don't
underestimate the amount of people that
on from the really put in the outputs
right now like you are Sam I think I
love only well recruiters and a lot of
people have sort of shared the
conversations they've had me where
they've called clients they're called
target clients name and they've heard
and they've um
replied going Sam you're the first
recruit that's called me it's you know
it's going on you know I mean so I think
if you're listening right now when
you're like yeah that makes sense but
honestly don't you may think everyone's
approaching like Sam is but they're not
tonight I mean so like really don't
underestimate the importance of being
busy and even if that is as your sense
I'm checking in speakings people people
will remember what you do and the
actions you take during this period do
you not I mean are they gonna remember
the recruiter Sam that called them
shared them on from this staff shared
tried to share value during this period
or they're gonna they're gonna want to
speak to someone that calls them and
says how you know he spoke back in March
before this went on hi Dan you know I'm
in so little value you you've got to go
edition and that's how that's how we
each really work for us chris is doing
save Don's doing the same it's really
worked wonders and you know there was a
time and a place to celestine to do that
so many people remember it right I think
I think that's the okay may love that so
I guess and what I begin I know we
really sort of dive into business
development there but I know a lot of
people get value out of that
I guess what I'd love to sort of just
unpack a bit more now you mention about
your Billings journey and increase in
performance I guess and this can tie
into it but why do you think Sam has
become a cornerstone in this business I
think a huge percentage of the
recruitment industry is subtend staff
smaller grown businesses and but why do
you think you're the person that really
grabbed the opportunity of both hands
and what did you do to ensure you became
that cornerstone in his business and how
I like because I want people to know and
hear about how you've done it because
they they can learn from that and do it
themselves and when you grab those
opportunities that they have in these
and in recruitment businesses right so
guess what why why why yeah why did you
why have you become that cornerstone I
wanted I wanted it more than anybody
else and anybody that wanted to compete
I wanted to really support crease and a
lot of things I wanted to learn and to
learn those I needed to adapt and I
needed to keep helping Chris so he had
the time to give me like did you did you
always have the mindset of it this is I
want to treat that it's my own business
yes yeah from from day one because of
all I always always wanted my own
business and Chris can I give me an
opportunity to have that I mean when
your own best be one thing but having an
influence and the influence I've been
able to have it was fantastic and I
really I don't think I
good manager I do think I'm a good role
I liked it I liked to I basically bleep
green right she I do I believe the TRC
colors and I just want one have one
needy and I wanted to role model I
wanted to show the people what you know
I keep that had five months experience
at Peugeot could could do and what they
could do and what they can achieve as
well did you make this really clear to
Chris as well like did you kill me did
you communicate this and say look Chris
this is what I want this is the this is
the opportunity I want this is where I
wanna be
this is what I wanna do did you over
communicate that yeah probably every
month ones minutes promotion when you're
gonna be quick I don't want any quicker
than everybody else but at the same time
I love that Sam I think it's so
important for ever listen and if you're
in a business and right now and you're
and you've got the Mintos a lot Sam has
you you want so I'm part of the business
you're in like make it clear really over
communicating and show that's what you
want and and I think this is one of the
great things about industry people will
reward it if you work for a good
recruitment entrepreneur there why would
you not want someone like you in the
business you know I mean and why they
not want to encourage you to want that
and give you the platform and the tools
to do that and so I guess obviously
we've spoken a lot about a lot of
positives clearly a positive guy what
you mentioned there they probably not
the best manager so one what have been
the challenges for you sound that you've
learned from what would have been some
of the biggest challenges for you in
this journey big challenges I've learned
see I come from I had I was a dispatch
manager for for EPS and I had 20 out
drivers and I thought I could manage
actually when you get into the
recruitment everybody you know everybody
wants to be that you know everybody
and I am right we have to and I realize
quite quickly that Chris can build a
team around me but I don't know whether
I could build the team and I think
that's how we you know I go out and put
the figures on the board I go out and
get business and pass it down and what I
want
he's maybe a four so we still have we
team underneath because I could bring in
that much business come on I don't think
of really managed together but Chris
picks up a lot more the upside and I did
the other stuff you know quite quickly I
don't think that's my forte but it's
something I have improved on and will
continue to improve I think I think a
lot of people a lot of people fall into
that boat mate yeah you're not alone in
that I guess what what are some of the
things that you had to change about
yourself so miss human was it Sam that
you wanted to be the best one to be the
top of the par which sometimes caused a
bit of friction internally when it's a
can be obvious it's a small or grand
business I don't know what what did you
have to learn to be better at did you
did you always want to take the
limelight from people like what did you
have to learn to get better at it wasn't
the line largely you got that naturally
but for me I'm very very very
competitive
okay sometimes you get ahead of me
you'll be sure that I'm gonna be up
there I wanted to be up there you know
that was just been challenges that they
had for me I'm naturally very compared
to you but sometimes I have to Rayna I
really do because my passion you can see
it and actually sometimes it's a bit
much because big yeah everybody saying
you know quick chris says you can't have
a roomful of directors you know that's
what he said everybody's different
people go by then why some people go
home and smash in front of the TV I
don't go to the gym more I do something
always doing something
I guess what M be interested to get your
focus on like looks because you're in a
obviously a growing business you get
also you can really see people around
like what from your perspective what do
you see in recruiters early on in their
journey as they go on that you think
sort of sometimes prevents them from
taking their Billings or performance to
the next level what the sort of common
pitfalls that you've seen them people
that are at the business or sort of come
and gone what are the typical things
that you've seen that you think's
prevented people taking their
performance to the next level do you
think work ethic and I don't think
everybody has its own work ethic I think
I don't think the crewmen can ever be a
job it's a lifestyle and you need to
live and you need to breathe it and you
need to take it home with you and you
need to you need to you need to do
everything you can with it you know I
think people get complacent sometimes we
you know you could have the best year
you know new people live coming in did
it have been a hundred thousand not just
in here friends businesses and stuff as
well but the only complaint that I've
achieved but what else are you gonna do
don't even joke eh what about younger
than 50 next year in two hundred there
you go keypad TV and I said this to you
earlier on um keep learning your market
it won't change my chair my market
changes every six months because it's
new Frank McCarthy something I keep
learning and keep innovating trying
different things which I different thing
because for me it's not one size fits
all so I guess to sort of them on that
point then like what
in hindsight what advice would you give
yourself knowing what you know now early
on then sounds recruitment courage you
think what would you say to Sam early on
and I'm what you know now what would I
say to myself do exactly what you do and
I sorry sorry - bye mate mindset that
comes up a lot on this right in terms of
what what's the difference between the
200k bit led to a friend replace
typically is it gonna be the you spend
more 30 minutes Morse but sending in
males or something like that probably
not it is that one set work effort these
types of things I guess
let's just talk about that for a sec
what's been your journey with mindset
may I know you said obviously I'm
definitely doing it from your parents
and you clear someone that wants it
you're competitive but like what did you
cultivate your mindset like what have
you worked on yourself was definitely
for me yeah I have this thing if I
didn't get if I don't get that one then
I'll get the next one it just fires me
up even more and this I don't mean to
sound arrogant with this and it's gonna
sound very arrogant but I genuine
believe that I can you believe in
yourself you're fully by yourself yeah I
need that and not only that I'm a big
believer that you know what's that work
for that recruitment company is also a
branding that recruitment company and
that's their the individual consulting
and I wanted to build a brand within the
brand and it's quite evident when you do
that business comes round and you know
it word-of-mouth he's very very
important and giving giving candidates
and clients are like the best possible
service is something I've always prided
myself on because you know candidates
what I've learned in these market
candidates become clients and truly
everybody the same to do the best you
can say to you so very early on you
recognize you've got you you gave
yourself very high standards and always
worked hard to work towards that never
always tried to not drop the bar 100%
you had to and I needed to make this
work for me as well you know I was going
for that time of my own where I was
eating I was 21 years of age didn't know
what I was going to do and I wanted to
make something work and when I found I
had enough at least as we sort of come
to finish this major just something
that's come up for me I think so how do
you know so if it comes in 27 yeah yes
we've got a young family mmm obviously
and and quite a bit of cash along the
way right what was what like Isla I
think recruitment going into it yeah you
can borrow these nice things gone nice
holidays I be for all this stuff right
but what just out of interest me because
I don't think enough people speak about
what's been your I think more people are
speaking about now but what's been your
sort of journey in finances like did you
start investing in property or like I
don't know what did you live you learn
and learn and learn is there because the
way Sam spent his money early 24 25
other know what might be a bit different
but what's been your sort of journey in
the sort of assets and things that you
built yourself because yeah yeah if I
said to you early on that I'm a bit of a
cowboy and believe or not I'm not even
joking if somebody across the road said
to me now John claim a car for 50 pound
I do challenging I mean you know
full-time director on within a
three-year-old son I got one on the
wagon for weeks so it's a busy time it's
keeping busy but this I invested in 22 I
go for a decent price and we just moved
into a new house now
and I'm not spending because I think you
always hated about people splashing the
cash in on this and I think like you
know I mean a lot of people in your
shoes caught could have just pissed it
all up the war and that means that in
situations like this now young family
might put yourself in a difficult
situation one so I think it's great to
talk about that at least and I guess
young family then Sam how's that been
for you mate
that's like let's not take that lightly
do you not I mean what how is that
journey being whilst being the recruiter
and family life personal life however
you how have you gone about juggling
that how does that been aa challenge I
mean
Archie's previous month but we decided
to tighten time to potty train I won't
go
Challenge and then Ellis about to pop
you know she's got another one on the
way but it's been good you know they
keeps it keeps you level-headed and
actually gives you gives you for me give
me I want to give him everything I
didn't yeah I didn't get and it doesn't
just mean you know he liked the ladies
trainers here you know the stable family
environment if you need to get it if you
need to go to extra classes at school he
gets you and did you find yourself have
just out of interest did you fight
because I've read this and the head is
quite a few times but Sam's Drive before
you had Archie compared to when you had
Archie did it did it level up did it
increase with your drive even more other
know what I guess he didn't crazy little
bit didn't change too much we didn't
reach because those how expensive they
are they come with nothing but no give
me more a driver supposed but to be
honest I've always been the same and I
just want to make sure actually you know
support my partner and everything that's
awesome and so before we finish then you
mention it just there why did you decide
to raise money and I have cycle however
many miles like what the hell went on
there may when I decided that I wanted
to do you're gonna laugh on the first
you know New Year's Day every year my
polynomial sometime acts of what we want
with you
and one of the things was I wanted to be
some charity and I coming today she was
a bit of a scary time and I need to
think
I needed something out so I didn't work
and I just need you something else to do
and I didn't know what it was
what about sponsored cycle now at the
time I didn't even have an indoor bike
right that could be the indoor bike come
on a Saturday and start my cycle on the
Monday so I thought okay how far can I
go
originally I thought I don't know I
could go a few miles you know I need to
I need to do some challenges so that's
where I went from John O'Groats London
and I thought I will do this you know on
the road actually I wanted to show my
support that right boy Sagi three four
hours sometimes a day to get that good I
finished early I've raised a shitload of
money how many miles did you cycle 874
and how not over what period 19 days 19
days and I was crazy that I did with my
friend Greg and Matthew from other
respective recruitment companies they
did it with me as well because they both
raised money for different charities so
the last died for a hundred-mile finale
- good that's crazy
I think that's great honestly a good
that the amount feels amazing defined
the two questions first one what what is
Sam most excited about when we come out
of kravid come well come away from
crying of ice what are you most excited
to do I don't know what what what comes
up for you what are you most excited for
when we start coming out of this just
going to shoot a big garden and a few
beers it's gonna be a new world so I'm
to see what's gonna happen we're gonna
every single person that goes back he's
gonna go back to a very very different
business and you know it's not it's not
going to be the same so I mean I'm keen
to see how that plays out not just for
us but for everybody I mean luckily
enough we still got a lot of people
working with other companies but to
further what a lot of people and they'll
go back at st. so just be keen to see
you know what happens but fundamentally
I'm just I mean I just hope everybody to
stay safe and everybody's okay
upon returning to work and let find a
question you can answer it with a phrase
or sentence of words whatever comes up
for you Sam but if Sam could communicate
every single recruit out there they'd
listen to your advice they'd take it on
they'd implement it tomorrow what would
you say to the people stay busy and
going to every day with the right
mindset I love that Sam it's been a
pleasure man thank you